my experience patrols is very limited
but the one that I like the most is the
ones that you get at Costco which is
delicious it's like the size of a big
ass like sugar cane I think it's
fantastic but you said that this is the
truth this is how troll should really be
made behind a truck or they just slice
that [ __ ] off into the oil so hopefully
it's delicious you're out of your [ __ ]
lawyer we are up here in East LA we're
about to hit up this churro spot and
into Tom Davis these are life-changing
churros that really ever seen an entire
lighting tool I put a little quick
disclaimer everybody says the same [ __ ]
every time they introduced it to it to
me and usually it's [ __ ] so your your
life is dependent on this
okay thank you
oh you said this is the best hurl in LA
and you said that the moment you had
this everything else was considered a
lot don't set me up for disappointment
I was [ __ ] good dude this is one of
the greatest things about LX you have
this random pass place there's a brick
Donald the Chase Bank mill the street
and you have this dude with this part
pulling this trust is making random
trails on the side the street and
there's actually one of the best shows
I've ever had in my life
that's why I [ __ ] love LA
beautiful [ __ ] good huggers sorry
Costco
like Akira
the asker one tastes like [ __ ]
hot-ass hot you weren't still decent oh
it tastes like wallpaper paste or
something yeah prefer to this I found
this place it's actually driving down
Whittier we're looking for target
readily the second a tickle fight
like my whole life has been alive up to
this point
so [ __ ] good can you reenact your
first facial expressions
it's weird because you go to lightning
like Disneyland or whatever and I know
there's no like reputable sources but
people always talk about Disneyland
churros or Costco
you'll see them make a fresh it doesn't
taste like this familiar recipe
portrayal generation my grandfather make
churros and political Mexicans this is
our refrain and we stay tuned for five
years I like to hear that
thank you what's the secret the secret
is the recipe for our families tell us a
secret you're right everything was a
[ __ ] life everything philosophy all
the trails I've had before did not taste
like this I have been lied to my whole
life it's crazy because like the trial
compared to other ones that we've had
it's really like and you would think
that because this is a deep-fried bread
you would get tired of it but I just
kept shoveling it into my face and I'll
contrary to popular belief because I'm
fat you think I eat like that normally
but I don't but this churro I did crazy
good crazy well you can find this on
Whittier it's a place called
a dawn I bet she slaughtered the
language it not done evil
I think they only have one location
right now so giving them a quick
shout-out because it's a small business
and it's just the best show I've ever
had if you guys want to have a good food
experience these are the types of places
that you have to go you don't have to go
to a [ __ ] fancy restaurant just know
Davis L sent you here